hey everybody and welcome to a brotherly
wild ride with stevo we've got we man
and not only can i say that i consider
him a brother but
there's a chapter in my new book that's
called everyone needs someone who will
call them an [ __ ]
and
we man's the star of that chapter in a
big way wow did he call me an [ __ ]
wow was he right
and wow am i grateful to have people in
my life like that so man
uh not only am i excited about my book
coming out on tuesday i'm excited about
this episode with we man we really get
into it
ah
juicy fun stuff about life business
and fame god it's uh
i needed to get a bunch of stuff off my
chest about how
overwhelming it can be since this last
jackass movie came out it was like
it's been it's been a lot a really
noticeable difference and man do we talk
about that in intimate detail
um so yeah i feel great
dare say i look great and i'm not taking
full credit for that i'm giving credit
for that
at least partially a lot to athletic
greens
and ag-1 which is the most convenient
comprehensive nutrition you can get
daily nutrition in one little pack or
one little scoop loaded with 75
different vitamins minerals
whole food source superfood
probiotics adaptogens this stuff is not
only delicious but i think it's the
healthiest stuff you can put in your
body i really do it fills in the gaps in
your diet if you're not eating all super
nutritious food then a scoop of ag-1 is
gonna make the difference it doesn't
just
fill in your your nutrition gaps it
helps with your gut health it helps with
your brain
and uh
and it's really delicious um i'm so
happy that uh i haven't had my
ag-1 yet today because i get to have it
now and you can have it too
plus
with your first order you can get five
of these free comprehensive convenient
nutrition packs plus an entire year of
immune boosting vitamin d
if you go to athleticgreens.com
stevo simple as that man you can check
this stuff out it's every bit as good as
they say i swear by it every day i love
it you're gonna love it too so go to
athleticgreens.como
and now without further ado
let's get into it
and i promise i won't freak out
right would you freak out about it it
was just so hot it was like 100 degrees
something and like the ac was shutting
off and we were doing one it was just
like an oven in here and i and i was
like the third podcast of the day too
okay here we go
ladies and gentlemen
we man
yeah
dude yeah dude i love it so much
when somebody who i did a podcast with
on zoom
can then
oh finally comes back in it's oh yeah
it's my first time in the van right yeah
yeah we had to unzoom as like episode
i don't know four four or five it's
pretty early in the pandemic
i remember too it was uh
a question we were trying to do it in
person and the pandemic had just become
a thing yeah and you were like oh you
know like i'm living with somebody who's
immunocompromised and it's just not
responsible yeah for me to do that i
gotta do it on zoom my ex was uh she's
like
uh type one diabetic so
she was yeah and so i was like
no i got and it was crazy
during that time i only stayed home for
a month i could only last
indoors one month and we're so lucky
because we've got [ __ ] vans we can
yeah it was rad i do i was camping so
much
and barbecuing
all right the time during that time that
was your deal on instagram live i was
yeah i was a grill master and i i'm glad
i was because now
going barbecuing anywhere or cooking
anywhere i just i got it down
what's your uh
method are you using propane or using
coals i use i use everything i cook from
either like wood in a fire pit
to propane on uh like a griddle grill i
do that and like uh
different uh
briquettes you know to smoke and do
different things like i learned how to
smoke meats i learned how to use a
griddle
i did like straight raw fire barbecues
like in a pit
so yeah it was a good time it was
perfect like i think a lot of people
learned something new during that time
and that was mine
yeah i mean
i learned how to [ __ ] talk over
people on a podcast
no
they didn't learn it then you were
already doing it way before podcast
yeah do you think that you're going to
get into like the rv lifestyle or are
you going to stick to the wait i might
get into it no no because he
you guys have what do you call this
versus like the rv this is a class b
motorhome oh class b motorhome and then
one class b and then you have a class a
for tour classic aim for tour yeah this
is my tour box so do you think you're
going to get into the class a lifestyle
i think down the line i am
it's so rad i love love so much dude i
love it too and i love i love being on
the road and in nature you know because
we we're here in the city wherever you
know we live and we're just always
around cars and traveling when i just
get out in nature
i'm just so stoked i'm just like phone's
gone
turn on some music light a fire and just
chill yeah
yeah it's good and the the lifestyle i
have anyway is more like not around
people too like
i woke up this morning to skate before i
came here and i knew like i have to be
at the park for the kids because right
if i want to session in that's when i
have to go right so yeah you've always
been kind of a more
private
dude like yeah i mean you've been always
like super cool with people like you
know oh of course i'll always be super
cool with people and stuff and all that
yeah you taught me though that uh
the people
aren't supposed to ask you for pictures
while you're eating
yeah
i just don't get it
like
that's where you got it from yeah we man
taught me that how about when it's like
someone who's actually working at the
restaurant
that is the word like okay you know
which door i'm gonna exit yeah just like
the bathroom too i've had dudes right
come into the bathroom and my bros have
been there too and i'm like dick in my
hand taking a piss dude let me get a
photo
right
and i'm like every restroom only has a
one way in and a one way out like
wait outside the restroom we were at the
ufc in vegas and some guy steve was
pissing in the urinal and some guy came
and put the phone in front of him while
he was peeing in the interval
i've never seen steve get so pissed
before in my life i would have been
waiting
dude i'm gonna make a youtube video you
like backhanded the phone out of his
hand you were so pissed like i've never
seen you react like that but like it was
i almost stepped in but i'm like that's
not even my fight like but that was like
so uncalled for that it's like i'm
[ __ ] taking a piss dude that's pretty
crazy i got physical with the guy had a
ufc fight
i'm your biggest mercy ever not there
your testosterone level
went up you you were like for sure
you don't remember that i i vaguely do
you blacked out you're so pissed yeah
yeah i i do i remember that what are
other no-no's for you i i had this one
guy the other day this was
i was in
was this one texas or georgia i was just
on our tour for uh didn't need to say
you just went to atlanta and then you
went to texas i went to atlanta for on
saturday flew out that night and i was
in texas on sunday and we're what was
that for chronic tacos we it's been
around for 20 years i've been with the
brand for 14 but it's been around for 20
years and we're going to all our shops
to like thank the community meet and
greet and take photos i see it on your
instagram where it's like current tacos
meet me with we men and i'm like man
like free tacos
somebody can win free tacos for a year
free catering they can get you know so
and because it's your company presumably
like you're not charging a fee to do the
meet and greet no franchise fee no
charging nothing
it's uh
dude that's a good deal right like when
jackass 3d came out and you had the the
tigers at the roosevelt hotel oh no i'm
i'm saying in the movies
[Music]
and it was like they put it on the
screen sponsored by weman's chronic
tacos they leaned into it yeah and it
was they thought it was funny to lean
into it and it was like i wonder if you
could put a dollar amount of value that
that like
i have the craziest story for you right
now
paul walker and his brother caleb walker
were at our premiere so the first time
it showed and they saw that and they
said to each other that's the restaurant
we got a franchise
and they franchised it they had caleb
walker now his brother his brother that
so he has two brothers paul walker and
caleb's the one who looks like him and
plays him in the the last movie that
furious passing fiercely was and they
came and they franchised because they
saw in the dark dude we met like what do
you mean they franchised they bought a
couple stores they they
opened
yeah they have one in huntington beach
the that's their bellaterra it's yep
it's the walker families wow yeah
they're part of the chronic taco like
family they're one of their franchisees
yeah what jackass 3d did for the brand
of chronic tacos has to be like that
yeah it has to be a lot that's one big
thing right there you know right
so they were he told me because we were
thinking of doing another restaurant and
then we go there and we sit there and
paul looked at him and goes no we're
doing this well how many stores did you
have at the
j3 at j3 i think we had three or four
right no we the the brand's been around
for a little bit i i joined it started
in 2002
and by the time i joined in 2008
it had 26. oh wow and then how many do
you have now we have 50 now but we've
gotten up to 60 60 so there's ones that
have closed ones that have opened like
we've gone through a lot of damage
served to trim the fabric oh we did
definitely trim the fat during the
pandemic yeah but now ever since
we're on a roll like it we're we're even
in l.a so what are the chances
realistically
of us getting stevo's hot sauce for your
butthole into chronic tacos done yes
you're my bro dude
i remember we were talking about at some
point like a stevo uh like veggie
burrito kind of a situation or something
yeah i don't know if that makes sense
but dude no the stevia hot sauce it
means
dead right here that would mean sign
sealed and delivered
friday friday when we go to the when we
go to type box yeah and we're doing all
that i'll make the call and we'll maybe
like i'll stop by on the way down and
we'll ship them out
that's cool yeah
way to go and uh don't you guys have
something else going on friday too yeah
well the reason we're going down to
tight box packing is to sign our new
skateboard what do they look like it's
huge
surprisingly you should ask wow boom
right here it's me and we man in
heavy metal regalia spandex animal print
pants
just
animal print headbands like
just chopped up heavy metal shirt like
oh it's so dope but what people have to
know too
these aren't heat transfer graphics
these are screen printed
old school yeah old school style and
look at all the colors we did there's 16
colors
we did not have ass at all this is a
dying art the art of silk screening and
you know what else we're not
half-passing is the shipping of these
beautiful boards to our wonderful
customers because we use shipstation and
it is just the topest notch
one interface that brings together all
of your e-commerce activity
and makes it easy to use whether you're
shipping stuff on amazon etsy your own
website doesn't matter it all comes into
one interface and it brings in all of
the different shipping methods fedex ups
post office and it gives you the best
rates that you can get rates which are
normally reserved for fortune 500
companies all in one place couldn't be
easier when you get your order
you print out your label boom and that's
how i ship
all of my merch all of it and
you can do it too plus you can get a
60-day free trial if you go to
shipstation.com
and then on the front page you click the
microphone in the top right corner plug
in the promo code stevo and you're off
and running with a 60 day free trial
hassle free
and
you just figure out how easy it is and
how much it can boost your business
because selling stuff online is the way
to go
so get to it go to ship station
shipstation.com click the microphone in
the top right corner plug in the promo
code stevo and make ship happen
like we are with these boards available
at stevo.com
now
let's talk about these boards a little
more
we we're doing these boards for real
that's cool and uh yeah
i loved when you sent me you so i had a
photo in wild boys where i looked
exactly like this
because we did a heavy metal uh blood
bath or something it was it was the
rattlesnake no no the the snake bite
tattoo
tattoo we were all meddled out and i had
a photo by myself like this and steve
was sent it to me because dude i've
always loved this phone i'm like oh
thanks
and then next thing you know he's like
dude let's do a metal board together
yeah and i'm like if that's what you
want to do bro i'm down i got it like i
i've fallen in love with skateboarding
just all over again man like uh not that
i ever wasn't in love with it but i've
actually i consider myself a born-again
skateboarder and i've been a born-again
skateboarder many times but like
it happens to everybody
because you go through these phases
there's there's times where right you
know and and it's life in general you go
through like different things and you
stop a little and then you come back
like but uh but due to everything
that's good in my life
you know people say everything i need to
know i learned in kindergarten and i i
really believe everything i need to know
i learned from skateboarding that's
every skater's thing dude skateboarder
yeah
and a lot of people outside of
skateboarding say
skateboarders in general in life
are gonna make it and the reason is
you go out there every day and you fail
fail fail fail
until you make the trick that one time
and that feeling you get
so in life you're gonna fail like
they're in everything you do you're
gonna fail
life's not perfect but for somebody else
who doesn't have that feeling all the
time
the first time they fail can be very
traumatic and they might not fail
like through school or whatever they may
do super well get a's all the way so
they're just it's it's like the dopamine
of like instagram their whole life
and then they get fired from a job and
it's like the end of the world they just
failed and they don't know that feeling
because it's the first time they've ever
had failure rejection yeah rejection
that that that is a huge part of it also
like
just the sacrifice i mean it's so
[ __ ] difficult you know like
i i had an interesting conversation with
with uh with tony hawk where i was
saying that um i started skateboarding
after i saw the first back to the future
movie in 1985 and that year because of
that back to the future movie it's like
there was a skateboard underneath every
[ __ ] christmas tree in the world like
skateboarding was the biggest fad every
[ __ ] kid got one and in short order
like
90 of those [ __ ]
kids discovered wow this shit's
difficult and i fall down and it hurts
like and they just gave up on it and the
only kids that stuck with it were the
kids that were willing to just [ __ ]
make that sacrifice you know like like
skateboarding weeds out [ __ ] yeah
weeds out quitters and it just it just
distills down
the the [ __ ] just hardcore people who
will go for it and persevere and [ __ ]
is that why you got into skateboarding
because of back to the future yeah
really and and uh and then tony hawk
described that wow that's interesting
that you think of that like uh the
biggest boon for skateboarding was
because of tony hawk's video games yeah
that was a huge one for all those in the
ninth like 97
2000 later when did the first one the on
playstation come out it was like 98
i don't know that means that tony hawk
did the 900 famously in 1999 and i think
that that made like oh that that created
the momentum
it was because
uh my character after they did it came
in on pro skater 2
and like they were already it was
booming that
that's already was that was that super
lucrative for you
what do you mean
having a character in people still talk
about it right but but did they pay you
a bunch of money
uh
i remembered like i had a character in
tony hawk's underground two like it was
like a secret character that you had to
like find and unlock and then you'd be
stevo riding around on a mechanical bull
through the game
and uh like to have my character i got
paid five thousand bucks like that i
think i got yeah i think i got the exact
same thing but you're saying like on the
first one like those people that made
the characters are like set oh all those
dudes all the main characters like
alyssa steemer bam bam kareem musca
rodney all those guys life changing
money that yeah that was what do you
mean like like over mill
i think so i think so and i had that
they may have gotten royalties
yeah i think it was life-changing money
i think they got royalties and for all
of the um
like piracy and [ __ ] in the world like
you know like goddamn video games you
paid
60 bucks for the disc
that costs
two bucks to make i mean it's the best
that's even two bucks
it's the biggest [ __ ] profit margin
yeah ever yeah in the world and i don't
i somehow think that you couldn't like
uh pirate them
either i think that uh at that time i
yeah i don't think i mean yeah you can't
buy like one kid buys one copy and goes
dude i got it all for all of us chip in
music you can do that with music since
back in the day but i don't think that
ever applied to video games i think i
don't think that they that they were uh
hemorrhaging money is that how people
are still playing video games a disc or
is it like a netflix thing where you can
like
now it's streaming you're not gonna
believe this uh-oh i [ __ ]
we went into best buy and i was just
like yeah [ __ ] i want to get i wanted to
get like a new coffee maker for the tour
bus and i walked down the aisle and i
see this [ __ ] super suped up [ __ ]
steering wheel with foot pedals and i'm
like man it'd be kind of fun to [ __ ]
be playing race car
on the tour bus while we're driving
around and then i learned in order to
use that [ __ ] steering wheel you have
to buy a console and i go oh my god am i
about to buy an xbox video game console
it goes against everything you [ __ ]
did everything
i
did if you bought that i did it but i
lost the cord to the things we're never
able to use it what cord you bought the
whole console i bought a console and the
steering wheel [ __ ] so that we
could [ __ ] race cars while we're
driving down the road for what game you
don't even know what game you got
oh my god never even got it to work and
sitting on the tour bus just as a
reminder that i [ __ ] failed
there you go failing again
that is just a dumb thing
yeah well that's cool but video yeah
video games like [ __ ] big money if
you're an actual like main character
yeah if you develop one did you ever see
there was like some big video game
contest this was like this right because
for covet or whatever and it was like a
16 year old kid like beat out like 5 000
people playing like fortnite like
whatever one of those yeah and won three
million
like he's like all right hey mom and dad
you now live at my house yeah or like on
tick tock you can see like some of those
[ __ ] smoking hot chicks that are just
on twitch playing video games making
bank cheese dude that's like the biggest
thing in
[ __ ] youtube maybe not anymore but
and this is why i hate video games is
because i think that like
i think that it's just a a criminal
waste of time and energy and effort
what do you mean like
like you know criminal waste like
somebody who's in jail just plays no no
i'm just let's say like you got really
good at a video game okay okay where did
that get you in life you know like
stuck on the couch that's what i always
said like uh i you know
like how how does being good at video
games get you laid you know or get you
paid
you know and i couldn't figure that out
like okay so you're just putting a lot
of genuine work and time and effort into
something that's not going to benefit
you in life well now people on twitch
are getting paid and late right and i'm
trying
dude there's some [ __ ]
banging ass are they getting laid in the
real world or the meta the metaverse
then came the phenomenon of people
whiling away useful hours of their life
watching videos of other [ __ ]
playing video games
yeah i mean my cousin's watching like
minecraft like people like
playing and talking about like narrating
their whole experience i saw i was on
an american airlines flight i think or
some european flight and uh in their
little video on demand library of the
airplane there was a documentary called
are video games really dangerous or do
does video game violence lead to real
life violence and i thought oh that's uh
an interesting topic you know like i
watched the whole thing and they said uh
basically to paraphrase what the whole
takeaway was is that there is no link
between video game violence and
real-life violence but there's a huge
link between like uh playing video games
and being a complete [ __ ] loser
i think that that's why americans are
fat and [ __ ] lazy and unmotivated
because they're not getting outside and
exercising they're sitting on the
[ __ ] couch playing stupid video games
yeah i wonder why that is i mean you
grew up in germany alienated no i think
i grew like summers and stuff there
it's i don't they ride bikes everywhere
but
here speaking of that
when i was a kid
my bike was my freedom like you rode
everywhere and then my skateboard was
the next one yeah you know but before my
skateboard was my bike like you got out
of the house and you rode your friend's
house sure rode and went to the beach
with your friends and stuff it was
freedom
no joke i was at a
clothing company the other day
and they had like a hundred of the same
little kid bikes they're like ones that
they don't even have pedals it's that
kids used to like pedal like with their
feet and then they had a couple bigger
ones
and we're like hey what what's with the
bikes like why so man this isn't even
what you do like
and they were like
we donate these to schools
for pe and stuff
and the lady goes do you know that
right now
in the states
80
of youth young kids and all that
don't know how to ride a bike wow eighty
percent i thought you were gonna say 80
of americans born after
year 2000 will develop type 2 diabetes
but it's not 80 it's like
and it is past 2000 to 2000. because
right now
2001 is when 21 year olds are were born
right isn't that crazy 2001.
somebody was born in 2001 is 21 this
year that's why i graduated high school
yeah i mean people are riding like
electric scooters now like they're not
yeah they don't even
even use power i mean dude like the
diabetes is so gnarly and like
like
it's
i i forget what the actual number is but
it's
i think one in three i think one in
three minutes one and three because if
it is 30 35 percent it is i saw that
statistic one in three americans born
after year 2000 will develop type 2
diabetes one in three that's how [ __ ]
awful
the
the
nutrition
and the physical therapy like
physical education no exercise shitty
diet
just go to school and play on your
computer sit on your [ __ ] soap on
your [ __ ] phone and don't exercise
and eat dog [ __ ]
jesus yeah
what got you into skateboarding
oh it was my uh i i always wanted i used
to read like surfer magazines and stuff
never got really into surfing but in the
back page
was always the skateboards and i always
dug him like i want a skateboard and
then my mom of course separated from my
dad and she went out with this surfer
dude who skated and she bought him one
one time like at a skate shop and i was
so pissed
i was like that's what i want you know
it's like
eight or nine years old where were you
living at that time hermosa beach oh
okay yeah we were in hermosa at the time
and uh i was like that's what i want
and like it was either like christmas
that was next or my birthday and i got
one
and i never put it down ever since what
was your first board uh it was like a
veraflex like the doctor i had it was a
robot that said the doctor on it and
then my next
real board was uh rodney mullen i i have
it tattooed on me because
freestyle board and i was street skating
on i was board sliding curbs
on my rodney mullen freestyle yeah
uh
1987.88 oh wow okay yeah
i had one i had 101 trucks i'm one year
older than oh okay
yeah
you just turned 48 i just turned 48.
yeah i'm 49. yeah you were born 74. yep
i'm 73 yeah we're one year apart
so when do you turn 50
may the next may
damn yeah we're about exactly a year
apart yeah do you have plans for the big
5.0
i haven't decided yet because
i'm in this and i'm like this i don't
know what's been going on this like this
last year we've been doing so much
and and i don't know if it's because i'm
49 and i feel like i'm like
where am i at this point in life
i love skating i love always that's what
i want to always keep doing now that's
happy to me
but
i'm like i i go everywhere
and i'm just like all right this is cool
you know whateves been all over the
world everything
and i'm like what do i want it like
really do i need to like
go out with a bang like party wasted 50
or do i want to plan something cool and
go far away
and be like i did something pretty rad
for 50. yeah you know
which is which is more of my take
cause anybody good
luck like all the babies crazy party
like you know and where haven't you been
and where do you want to go you want to
go like mongolia or you want to go to
like i can't picture jason wanted to go
to mongolia i mean you've already been
to like asia yeah i haven't been to asia
but i've even been to korea
we were like like us together
have we've been to
uh thailand
kenya india
india japan japan
um and and dude like all over the states
all over canada we're in australia
together right where we are well yeah we
work for the 2006 thing yeah foreign
yeah
where would you want to go though and
where would you want to go you've been
everywhere when we were in in cancun
that was uh jesus hey that was that was
nuts that was weird what year was that
we went to canada it was like 2003 2004.
no no it was 2001. with donald oh that
was to the that's the first time that we
because it was before the movie it was
between the show and the movie
and we sold out the largest nightclub in
mexico with
what we didn't even know was a show
we just showed up yeah and what you got
how long have you guys known each other
before that i mean we had like not since
jacket jackass was the first i would we
never met until
we were filming the second season of
jackass
yeah because the first season we all
filmed and just yeah put the put the
[ __ ] in like everybody okay bam and
everybody from that's everything was
filmed separately and just and then put
it together so somebody was like come
out to cancun we're partying and then
you guys showed up and there's a show
yeah you know what's crazy i met nick
dunlap before stevo
he got my number from like your
chick or something yes
yes i meant nate was my first ever
representative yeah
so that was pretty crazy and that's a
pretty crazy one to have in the books
but
suffice it to say we've been all over
the world together
now you said something about getting
wasted there was a period where you were
sober
yeah
for four years four years and then you
like now you just like just rock
no
i have
uh and and during covid
kind of did it again because it was like
all right go skate and then barbecue and
then drink sounded like on shark week he
got pretty hammered in the airport oh
yeah i did
i got hammered in shark week the whole
time
but what's so crazy is and it's so funny
and i don't mean to bring him up
but bam always like when when we were
talking about jackass four right like
you can't party you can't do nothing
right why is gay man allowed why is we
man allowed to go party and all that
music because we man's not showing up in
jails and psych wards and rehab yeah and
it's like we man's not like
one time i tried to uh
i was just trying to get through to bam
and i was like
i i just
typed into the search bar of tmz
bamardera just to like just kind of go
through
just the feed of his art and it was like
so gnarly
just one thing after another everything
it was just like i was just like bam it
was like trump typing in trump on cnn or
something like it just like
you don't have to go to rehab you're not
showing up in jail
yeah and i don't know
i don't wake up and go oh dude i need to
party you know right right right i'll
just like if it's a good time and we're
having a good time when's the last time
you've been drunk
last night no
uh over the weekend i got it wasn't i'm
like i just get buzzed with you know
because i was out with the chronic taco
dudes yeah yeah i don't go out and get
like crazy like we used to we used to go
out and we'd be like fine chicks party
ball you know
and now it's just like adult style
we just ah have a good time
yeah i mean back in the day i'd be
[ __ ] so gnarly yeah like you never
did cocaine nope never did it once bless
we man's heart for never doing cocaine i
will say he's about to spill the beans
on all the drugs that he actually has
done and that's okay because he's
communicating it's important to do that
you know it's very helpful to do that
with a therapist
and so now a word from our sponsor
better help
betterhelp.com
is
the place to get linked up with a
top-notch qualified therapist so that
you can work your stuff out man i mean
you take your car to get an oil change
right
you uh you go to the gym to keep your
body fit why wouldn't you maintain your
peace of mind man i do it i see a
therapist regularly and i feel way
better off for it i think you will too
if you haven't tried it i think it is
worth a shot and the way to do it is at
betterhelp.com
that's better
h e l p
dot com
slash devo so that you can get 10 off of
your first month and when you get there
you're going to fill out a quick and
easy
questionnaire to get matched up with the
perfect therapist for you you'll be able
to switch therapists if you want and
really i think it's very much worth
giving giving it a shot they're helping
untold thousands of people including
myself i feel very good about it and i
feel very good about suggesting that you
go to
betterhelp.com
devo again for 10 off your first month
and it's already the most affordable way
to get therapy so go to betterhelp.com
and now let's talk about we man's drug
use
yeah cause i i remember uh
like i would be like
would you travel with cocaine to other
countries
ah
yeah i definitely did
these guys
definitely kept me off of cocaine
because with these guys he means me
because we would be out
and then it would just be stevo like
yeah i did i'm gonna start a t-shirt
coming i'm gonna have a car come like
and i'm like
dude that's all these dudes do is party
all night
they get the guy who [ __ ] got them to
drugs now is their new best friend
and all these dudes do all night is just
tell each other the next venture they're
gonna do it's the worst and i would i'd
want to kill all of them because i'm
like
deeper on tour we gotta do [ __ ] or we
gotta film tomorrow and you're just
sitting
in hawaii yapping about blah blah and
i'm like i'm gonna kill you
i'm like i'll never do that
and i've had
piles in front of me i've had it put in
my hands
like at parties like here you go and i'm
like oh [ __ ] this
yeah that's that that's good did you
ever smoke a cigarette
yeah i did okay yeah i've smoked weed
too have you ever done e never done any
never done mushrooms mushrooms is like a
hot thing right now where everybody's
doing mushrooms
like nap
but never did acid never did acid never
what oh
did whippets
no you never gave them to me me and my
buddies just did a couple
and i didn't like it it was that weird
like
oh no don't want to be there yeah yeah
dude so
with uh chronic tacos
like it's it's the business is doing
exceptionally well yeah it's it's
picking up momentum and
like uh i think it was before the
pandemic you were saying that uh
you know that chronic tacos
your
your goal is to build it up build it up
and then sell the whole company for just
a monstrous amount of money and retire
it's still the dream yeah
are you close to that dream
can't talk about it yeah that's that's
something yeah we can cut that out no
that's fine i'll i'll mention that you
know we just don't i mean that's a
perfectly viable business plan yeah we
talked to rob durdick yeah dear dick
about uh
he's done it
over and over over and over again that's
his goal yeah i wanted to do it
with merge four socks too and we just
got to a point and
i love them and all that but i stepped
down off the board of that too
yeah
you know you
but yeah but with chronic i've been with
so many years that
uh you know eventually it will yeah it's
uh every
every fat and i don't call this fast but
i call it like fast casual but every
fast food brand is under another
umbrella of other companies you know
what so
what was it chipotle's owned by
mcdonald's yeah right
and taco bells by pepsi really yeah yeah
i thought the whole thing with chipotle
mcdonald's was
they funded them in 2003 and then they
if it like sold it off like an oh nine
or two they may have i don't remember
the last thing don't uh
yeah take my word for it yeah but yeah
it could be it could be in that
situation but
i even think nowadays they might even be
under another umbrella probably even big
nice restaurants
are all under
umbrellas of other companies right you
know um
you were like were a professional
skateboarder for dog town like way back
in the day and
then i remembered like a a number of
years back you started your own
skateboard company called nullity yeah
and put together your own team yeah but
then you've uh more recently had boards
come out with dog town and we can
reinitiate my board through dog town and
stuff and that did great we're gonna
probably want to do it again but i told
them to put it on hold because of our
collab yeah so i didn't i didn't want
them to like be like
back and forth with each other i wanted
that sold out so then it was like this
time we were we were talking about it
like oh no steve came to me and we're
going to do this yeah and i wanted to do
this
and you know just have that as the one
board out
okay so you just want to have one board
at a time yeah i mean maybe down the
line me and you'll do a 2.0 and i'll
have another dog town board out too so
yeah i think it's one of our best
the best design that we have right thank
you for that yeah i really like it yeah
dude i i love it as well um
you uh
your website weman.com
was
dark but it's still dark aren't they you
know if we're honest but you lost
control of it and scott randolph dug it
up and i don't know if i ever had it i
mean they were like yeah somebody bought
it in like 2003 or something like that
and then you thought you had it but you
didn't and so that then i was like
trying to negotiate i was like well well
let's see if they send you like a a
two-step verification
and i was like okay they said they sent
you a verification did you get it and
you're like nope
yeah i was like yeah some some company
bought it out so
yeah i think kind of when like the
internet started or whatever and did all
that
i think somebody nabbed it before me
and i remember even trying to get it
and it was an irish guy and he goes i
don't know who we man is we're all we
men like out here
yeah and it's like that's what they just
call each other yeah and i was like [ __ ]
and then like after
so many years of getting even more
famous and more famous and more famous i
was like oh whoever has it is ready to
cash in i don't know what you guys got
it for but stevo and scott got it for me
and i'm like the most thankful right now
we're gonna have the boards on it i have
the t-shirt i have t-shirts being
because
you gotta have a website like yeah
you know the website is just like the
the hub it's like the dashboard for your
career is kind of how it works you know
it's where you want to send everybody to
your ecosystem yeah
um
speaking of uh getting more famous dude
is it crazy how
like i mean we've been around for 20
years you know people recognize us
wherever we go but
this last movie coming out like i really
noticed like the way it's a whole
different thing yeah it's like wow we're
like we're we're like
because i think the 10-year gap
right i mean
i just noticed it a lot and and here's
the thing too that [ __ ] kind of like
it it gets
it since this last movie came out it's
gotten to a point like where
it's actually really difficult to get
around in public because it's like you
know there's it's it's kind of just
overwhelming with like pictures and
and stuff like i don't even know dude
and it's it's it's to a
extent that like
it's impossible to to keep up with it
and it's impossible to not get like
but you know i find myself getting like
grumpy and i [ __ ] hate it man i've
been sleeping on a camera photo and i'm
like put it on something let's go go go
go get a like and i'm like sure
i haven't gotten that short with people
the lady says
i'm like
and the eating one the eating one
bothers me
it i'm not even joking
i think manners have gone away from
people like i'm being serious 100
because i would never go up to somebody
with like their hands on a burger and
like their mouth on it and go hey look
don't even say hello nice to meet you
anymore that's
been long gone where they sit in the
booth next to you you have that oh and
they just stare
but no but hold on yeah but they go like
can i get a photo
and you're like
hold on and then you you're you know
here i go and you feel bad and i'm like
can i finish eating and then oh okay
whatever but then it even comes to a
point where we're like well i'm going
okay well that's your time then bro
sorry yeah right but here's one that
really got me the other day
and i thought i was going to be like you
in the in the porta-potty or in the in
the urinal this dude like he like we
were out in texas and he messaged me
okay man i'm gonna be at the event
tomorrow
can you kick me in the nuts
and i'm like and i'm like hey i'll see
you there
and he comes and he's
i can tell he he wants he wants to be
famous i'm gonna say his look because
it'll give it away but he had a certain
look and all that
and he's like all right you're gonna
kick me i'm like no this isn't the place
what
i've seen all these other like he was
like stressing and in my face about it
and i'm like bro
i retired i retired from not kicking
yeah so did i
because then i realized what it does for
these people and
it's not what it does for them it's just
a bad it's not the energy i want to put
out yes now i'm not saying what it does
for people too but i think what it what
it does in their mind for them but but
the dude
like was like shaking i thought he was
gonna throw a swing at me and i was like
oh dude if this dude throws a swing at
me
he's on the ground like he's gonna go
down and then he just like walks away
he's like well i'm coming to l.a
and i'm like all right come on come to
l.a whatever like you know
and i'm like dude people
it's weird it's weird out there and the
one guy gave you titty twisters that one
time yeah
that's a gnarly thing i don't like that
um but yeah it's just crazy because i've
always been like really really
careful and and like it's just always
been really important to me to to be
good the fans you know like i'll never
turn down a photo and even when i get
the most grumpy and short like i'm
always just like put it on selfie hurry
up you're not like i'm still not turning
down the phone yeah yeah i know you just
like put it on selfie like but you know
yeah
i just um i i i really need to dig deep
and and uh
not get grumpy because i just don't you
know no i saw a comment on the instagram
thing it says like someone's like dude i
met stevo like don't believe everything
you read on reddit about somebody he was
super cool to me and i'm like
i'm like
they're talking [ __ ]
then my next thing i think is like dude
i got to do a reddit ama to be like hey
dude like reddit community like i wanted
to you know
and you go on there and like you prove
that it's you by by posting a photo
saying i'm gonna do an ama for reddit
okay and then they know it's gonna be
you and then they're just typing in
questions and you just
type answers to the questions you want
to and the ones that are most popular
get like upvoted so like it's a system
by which they feed the most compelling
stuff to the top yeah
and all of reddit works that way so if
your ama
is you know popular it gets upvoted
uploaded so you rank on reddit based on
how much the community is enjoying the
content got you all right and uh i care
so much about what people think about me
that was why i'm like i gotta [ __ ]
make things right with reddit like i
can't have people out there
being thinking saying i'm an [ __ ] but
it just it
what it kind of leads to ultimately is
that [ __ ] when people get like
famous to a point it's
just too overwhelming so yeah like
[ __ ] what do you do
famous people
get branded labeled as like arrogant
[ __ ] and like i kind of
you know like bring me
you know what you know you know what
though
when i was a kid i used to think oh that
was shitty that that happened to the
person because i would hear and this is
even for cell phones and stuff right
that you would hear stories about fans
going up to someone they loved right and
bothering them
while they're eating and the person
yelling at him and it gets bummed and
i'm like
you don't like if i came to you scott
and i was like scott give me a photo but
you just got off the phone
and something happened or whatever
something anything that now you're in a
bad mood
that i'm coming into you with your mood
that you know you can't make everybody
happy you can't there's no way i'm just
putting it
and i do the same thing but
there's no way you could or else
you wouldn't be making yourself happy
right but dude
i'm on the other side of it and i see
you guys and and i'm like i look at the
amount of photos that you guys take
and the trade-off is like okay be famous
or have i wouldn't want to be famous
because of that like you what you do a
mean greet for 50 people twice a night
there's 100 people you go out to walmart
or whatever there's 20 more photos
i i've seen you be cool with
150 people and then the one person that
comes up to you like that tries to be
funny or it's like bro just you know
hurry up and take my photo that one
person will do a [ __ ] reddit and
you're an [ __ ] but i just watched you
take 140 photos during the day 100
i don't want to take three photos in a
day at a family function dude but but
that's what it always is it's exactly
that and that's what i'm talking about
is the one right knucklehead that comes
up
and i i'm gonna call him knucklehead or
a random person or whatever
and i appreciate that and i love that
but now let me tell you this
like after the pandemic like uh coming
back onto tour two things that were
noticeably a lot more difficult than i
ever remembered them was going through
airports and flying on airplanes
and doing meet and greets it was just
like somehow like the time away during
the pandemic and then coming back to
meet and greets and airplanes those two
things were really [ __ ] difficult and
then now we're performing shows in big
theaters so i'm doing like 50 people
meet and greet after the show and
i was i was dreading it so i came up
with this [ __ ] thing and this is all
on me i was like you know what like if i
have a marker then everybody wants me to
sign something and it makes it take
twice as long so i'm gonna go into the
meet and greet deliberately not having a
marker and if somebody asks me to sign
something i'll politely say oh yeah you
got a marker and they don't have one
like oh well you know i don't have one
inside i guess i guess we're not going
to sign anything and that was my my
thing and it made the meet and greets go
by a lot quicker
but people would leave like man i wanted
a signature that's bummed right and i
was like i don't care because i just
didn't have a marker and then i saw a
[ __ ] comment on a youtube video where
someone says dude stevo i got the
[ __ ] meet and greet and
he like rushed me by and i couldn't even
get a signature and i responded to the
comment i wrote
it sounds like you didn't have a marker
[Music]
[Laughter]
i'm sorry you had a bad experience
dude and then i told lux about it
and we were at dinner we were on a date
and i'm like i saw the comment while i
was in the [ __ ] bathroom
and uh and she's like babe you gotta
[ __ ] be cooler this is people like
it's important they're meeting you and
i'm like you know what like [ __ ] lux
is right you know and and i'm just
saying from my perspective seeing that
[ __ ] comment and my [ __ ] response
to it
like i
[ __ ] it bothered me all night i'm
like [ __ ] there's this person out there
that's [ __ ] that i bummed out and
that and i decided then and there that i
would rather
be
[ __ ] miserable inconvenienced by like
a [ __ ] meet and greet that takes way
too long and make sure every person
leaves completely [ __ ] happy
then be inconvenienced and miserable by
a whole night of just [ __ ] feeling
shitty about a [ __ ] [ __ ] oh i see
what you're saying yes and now i'm not
i'm deliberately leaning into it to make
sure everybody leaves [ __ ] like they
[ __ ] were special and
let's say you go ahead and do all that
and you're making everybody happy then
you have the [ __ ] last person in line
or the middle person in line that's like
hey can you make a video for my niece
who's not here you know yeah i used to
go off on people i did when people would
ask when people asked me to make a video
i would i would like sometimes like kind
of funny and sometimes like to strip it
i'd say oh i see what you're saying i'm
not dealing with enough people
in person
now you're now you're introducing
third-party people just so that i can
have to [ __ ] deal with more [ __ ]
people
now you're making me tired of it
you're making me talk to people who
aren't even here because i'm not [ __ ]
working hard enough for you is that
right
i mean it's crazy and now you know what
i've done i do every [ __ ] video
everybody asks for it no questions same
place i do it every minute
because like the people listening are
probably going to say they're always
going to find something to say like oh
well they're complaining about being
famous it's like look it i'm not famous
i travel with steve i've been with we
met i've been with all those guys they
i've seen steve in in probably take
90 000 photos without a [ __ ] you know
what i mean and anybody in that
situation you would not be able to
handle the amount of [ __ ] photos that
they take with a good attitude so it's
like before anybody's like oh you know
you're just so ungrateful it's not like
that at all
i've seen them bend over [ __ ]
backwards i've seen you guys
somebody complains about oh i have this
niece with it you will [ __ ] send that
money or a flight
without even anybody even [ __ ] like
i'll want to do a video with steve where
i'm like hey let's go pay for somebody's
rent and you're like i would never do
that on camera and you'll go ahead and
do it off the camera so it's like the
amount of things that people see off the
camera it's like
yeah it always works for me when people
do good deeds [ __ ] for a video i
[ __ ] hate that dude yeah like
they're gonna pay your rent and they get
14 million views on the video and they
make like 20 [ __ ] thousand you know
what it's like yeah no we've we've
helped out i uh
and i'll just talk about because i've
already done it and i'll do it again
i've gone to uh walter reed hospital
and
like on christmas day
because there was times i didn't have a
lady or whatever and i would say like i
went with my family for thanksgiving
the injured vets injured injured any any
injured any medical they're it's the
first hospital they all come back to
when they're when they're in the states
and they get injured like limbs blown
off anything i mean dude you're big on
the uso mill like you've well yeah
yeah where have you gone on uso tours
i've gone all i flew around the world
did you go to afghanistan gone to
afghanistan
iraq iraq
one time one time we were with a
four-star general and it was me
like dallas cowboy cheerleaders
um the the couple other like celebrity
people and we were in helicopters taking
off in the rain already taking off it
was raining where we were and we're
going from like afghanistan to cutter
in the rain it was like a 30 minute
flight 10 minutes in because we had the
doors open and stuff i see
rockets being shot at us
and i'm like oh crap and people are like
what i'm like we're being shot at and
the pilot gets on um yeah we're gonna
turn around due to weather
we've been flying in the weather this
whole time we're being shot at is why
we're getting turned around oh
yeah
so
that's crazy what'd your dad do in the
uh military he was a cook
really yeah he was a cook he was right
after vietnam
my dad was a knucklehead too just like
us and my grandfather right when my dad
turned 18
dropped him off at the army recruiting
really it's like you guys
make him an adult you know what i mean
and my dad my dad's actually pretty
happy that he went and did that and it
did straighten him out
yeah yeah that's pretty so you've been
all over the middle east yeah you've
been everywhere how many countries have
you been to do you know how many
countries you've been to
i could i've been to quite a few i i i'm
ahead of scott by a little bit of
driving i'm like 50 he's like 58.
i'm gonna put my list down and i can i
can contact some people too all you
gotta do is just [ __ ] around with the
map and he's got a killer app what's it
called uh there's an app called cordell
told me about it ben
b-e-e-n okay like places you've been
yeah and you just click on the map and
and it'll generate like uh a [ __ ] map
colored in percentage of the world and
it'll say you've been to 20 of the world
or oh wow okay i'm gonna do that i i did
it old school with a big wall map of the
world and put a pin
i remember going into people's offices
yeah and they would do a pin that's
pretty rad no i'm gonna do it i i need
to i've been to places that people in
those countries haven't even been to
places in their own country yeah oh my
god it's crazy it's so crazy and when i
was in india i went to this place like
uh
some spot and 50 kilometers down the
road can people see your i came out
yesterday
on indieflicks it's called perfect chaos
i have a documentary where i rode a
motorcycle around india nice i'll share
the link yeah but it's uh i'd like to
see it too so yeah
and there'd be people like maybe
20 miles out and they're like oh my god
like it's such an honor that you're
going to this spot this bathing got 20
miles away i've lived here my whole life
i've never been i'm like dude you've
never [ __ ] been 20 miles away from
your house your village jesus i mean
it's wild yeah
yeah dude
where in korea did you go
i went all over seoul and then i went to
the dmx the or whatever the dmx all the
rough riders went with you yeah not the
dmx the the dmk uh the um the north
korea yeah i went to the holy [ __ ] you
went to north korea yeah and i went on
the other side of the border
and usually dmz the dmz at the dmx the
dmz
hello
[Laughter]
no but yeah the dmz and i and
it was pretty cool what was crazy is
you're right there and north korea is
right there and they have their flag way
higher because they want to see tougher
and
i'm standing there with my tour guide
for monster and she put her backpack
down on the stairs
and all of a sudden all these soldiers
are
like
the backpack's a bomb huh because north
korea watches over and they think it's
like a bomb but then we walked down in
and we were in that little like
uh room where you show your plans or
what's going on
and nobody was in there i'm like i'm
going to north korea and i [ __ ] went
over on the other side
wow
yeah so you can check north korea off
your country later
i've been in north korea you and rodman
me and rodman yeah
damn what's crazy is rodman i see him
all the time dude work is where he lives
yeah he's he lives in the same area
bumping into dennis rodman can be a lot
of work
as soon as he's around
i houdini out of the place i'm like
i mean
it can it's moving target sometimes it's
more work than others
but when he's on one it's rough didn't
he go to uh russia to talk to putin now
he tried to travel
it didn't happen
it didn't happen yeah
yeah and gotta wish that
man and can you imagine like an nba hall
of famer where you're like oh [ __ ] he's
here like let's dip
yeah dude yeah i mean with all the like
appropriate love and respect for dennis
rodman when he's on one it's a bummer
yeah he's a good guy
but yeah you you want to like oh yeah
you want to not you don't want to get
caught in his radar yeah
[Laughter]
yeah i mean like the only like worst one
when when someone's on one is andy dick
yeah
i i gotten pretty good at avoiding
tasmanian devils around you guys and
avoiding you guys yeah anytime you guys
were on well i'm like yeah not my scene
yeah so pretty pretty gnarly stuff so
you're in a relationship now and it's
going great it's been going super good
she's rad how long have you been
together year and a half a little over a
year now
yeah and we've gone we've gone to quite
a few places we just got back from kauai
that was a fun trip
we've gone to italy we've gone uh we
went to nashville and saw and went for
the fourth of july
big
bang show and then we saw rod stewart
the next day nice yeah so it's been it's
been fun how's the rod steward show dude
rod stewart still has it kicking soccer
balls on the stage still really hanging
out like kicking soccer balls like he's
that's what he's known for like after
one song or whatever he please keep up
with it i know he kicks him out into the
audience oh [ __ ] and the audience throws
him back and he kicks it again
wow how old is he now
i wanted 75 80. 78 or 81 right in there
wow like he's older dude
yeah dude yeah
who do you think crush more be rod
stewart or bruce springsteen
dude i don't know boss but i used to
live down the street
from his one old from heather whatever
that his one old lady that he was with
who rod stewart's lady yeah
heather's maggie no heather not maggie
from the song
so yeah
yeah dude all right and uh
dude i'm stoked that you mentioned your
documentary paul as you cut this i need
you to put in the flicks a little
yeah we man dot com is hot again yeah
and everybody
while you can get yourself a heavy metal
stevo weeman collab skateboard
autographed by both of us i might bring
a couple we still have a couple dates
left
on tour for chronic tacos and i might
grab a couple and
have scott ship them
with them i'll reimburse the brand
i'm going to make it happen folks if
you're a fan of the stevo and the wee
man and you're in chronic tacos you
might get yourself stevos yeah butthole
hot sauce and the way you asked for you
say excuse me can i get a little
something from my butthole
all right dear i love you brother thank
you love you too bud that was fun
gotta say i feel better after uh
speaking candidly about like the meet
and greets and stuff and just like
recommitting myself to being [ __ ]
like just even more available to people
you want to shout out video just ask
i'll do it no problem whatever you need
because that's where i'm at these days i
just want to be a great guy
and i also
i want you to read my book it's uh it's
really really awesome and it's coming
out this tuesday the sooner you order it
the better and of course don't forget
about the wee man and stevo skateboard
get a load of that look at that
hilarious
and as always i love my street team
thank you so much i will see you on the
road and i love you all
oh yeah scott's documentary is in the
description
yeah i almost [ __ ] scott